Let's now extend our
concept of momentum
to a system of particles.
Again, we need to choose
a reference frame.
So we'll have a ground frame.
And let's consider N particles.
Now when we have a
lot of particles,
we need some type of notation.
So let's use the symbol j.
And it will goes
from 1 to N. And then
our arbitrary j
particle will be moving.
This particle will have mass mj.
And it will be moving
with a velocity vj.
Now recall in our system, we
have many other particles.
We can call that one 1.
This is one n.
We have lots of different
particles in the system.
And this just represents
an arbitrary particle
in that system.
And the momentum
of the jth particle
is just the mass, mj,
times the velocity, vj.
And again, we're assuming
some fixed reference frame.
So the total momentum
of this system,
we now have to add
up the momentum
of all the particles, all the
way up to the nth particle.
Now, when we make
a sum like this,
there is a standard
mathematical summation notation,
which we'll write like this.
We'll do the sum, this capital
sigma sin of j goes from 1 to j
goes to N of the momentum
of the jth particle.
And that represents the sum
j goes from 1 to n of mj vj.
And this is what we call
the momentum of the system.
This is a vector sum.
And now let's see how
Newton's second law applies
to the momentum of the system.
Suppose that acting
on our particles--
for instance, here's our jth
particle-- we have a force
Fj acting on the jth particle.
Then we know that
from Newton's law
that the force will be also
the sum of the forces on all
of the particles, F1, F2,
plus dot, dot, dot, plus FN.
So once again, we can
write this as a sum
j goes from 1 to N of the
force on the jth particle.
And that's the
force on the summing
over all the forces on all
the particles in the system.
But now, we can apply
Newton's second law.
So Newton's second
law is the statement
that the force on
the jth particle
causes the momentum of the
jth particle to change.
And when we write that now,
the total force on the system,
j goes from 1 to N, is just the
sum of the change in momentum.
Because every single term--
let's just look at that.
T1 plus dP2/dt plus dot,
dot, dot, plus dPN/dt,
that's what we mean by the sum.
We can rewrite this as
d/dt of P1 plus P2 plus P3
plus dot, dot, dot, plus PN.
And what we see is
that the total force is
the derivative of the sum j goes
from 1 to N of the momentum.
But recall, this
sum we've defined
as the momentum of the system.
So our conclusion
is the total force
causes the momentum of
the system to change.
Now so far, all
we've done is we've
recast Newton's second
law in this form.
Our next step is to
analyze the forces
on the individual
particles we have
and apply Newton's third law.
So we'll do that next.